hey what's up guys my name is eternal
Lord episode 65 of game programming so
today we're going to take a look at a
very well a way better way of handling
collision basically it's way more
advanced and I'm going to cover it in
too much depth but I'll roughly show you
guys what it is because I had this idea
right a lot of you guys really want me
to get on with this game right you don't
to spend me you kind of just want to you
know I guess have a product that you can
um play around with and you know you
want me to implement all the basics for
you so that then you can well I would
hope earn from it so what I've been
thinking is I'm probably just going to
do that so what I'm going to do with
this series I'm actually going to split
this series into two different series
and they're with me I think this is a
good idea but I'm again like I think
this is a good idea you guys going to
let me know by leaving a comment below
but um basically my idea is to split
this game programmer series into two
series there's game programming which
yep and then there's game programming in
depth right which is the other I guess
spin-off series and what I'm craving
this so what my idea here is that this
series right right now basically just be
um I guess a much more concise version
of just game programming and in other
words I'm what we're going to continue
making realm of the mad God and I guess
wanted like just really concise right so
I'm not going to get into in-depth I'm
not gonna talk about how everything
works I'm not going to go over the math
for you I'm not going to draw you guys
diagrams in paint.net sorry that's over
I'm basically not gonna do any of that
stuff but instead I'm going to just
basically speed up the development
process and there's much code down as
possible it's still taping episodes you
know 10 to 15 minutes long I was
actually watching episode 1 yeah that's
right the other day um and I actually
said that I wanted to get the episodes
like three minutes long but you know I
didn't have it anyway so the deal is
again you know that it'll be 10 to 15
minutes but we'll actually I guess spend
more time coding and maybe um you know
basically speed up the development of
the episodes and then game programming
in depth is basically going to be
coloring all these concepts to lie
behind this game in depth so that is
where I'll crack open paint on out draw
you guys some diagrams show you guys
just basically so that like a baby can
understand it so in other words I'm
going to totally describe everything
cover all the maths with you guys even
draw I probably
my car my tablet so that I can and not
like a tablet like a tablet with a
screen but like those Wacom tablets the
old ones I guess they're not really old
but anyway so that I can like draw you
guys you know stuff with a pen basically
and you can see what I'm drawing and
basically explaining stuff you know in
depth so that's my idea right splitting
game programming into game programming
and game programming in depth where the
in-depth version will also will
obviously um be really in-depth but
they'll be on separate concepts so there
won't be like you know making something
from scratch
it'll still be a series but it won't be
like a sequential series so you don't
need to wash one episode to understand
another um but yeah that's my idea so
please guys leave a comment below
telling me what you think I think it's a
good idea but you know you guys welcome
to the side but I'm sure you guys will
be happy with it I'm just asking you
guys just in case but um yeah if you
think that's a good idea please express
your opinion blah and yes anyway let's
get on with this episode because I was
quite a long intro so we're going to
cover collision when I cover a different
way to do collision today so what we
have gone on right now is you know what
I like to call I guess a simple
collision I don't actually have a name
for it I was bluffing but um this is
like the most simple kind of illusion
that you do so that you guys can
understand how collision works and again
the way that it works it is about it
basically just checks the tile that
we're about to step into and if it's
solid it doesn't let us step onto it
that's it but the problem with this is
that right we kind of get this stuff and
it's just it's not really accurate is it
like you say that we're good here but I
mean you know it kind of just soppy on
look at these guys sorry bro I'm just
gonna have to quit our sky for you
anyway um anyway let's let's get back to
this um so we have this kind of
imprecise way of doing stuff and I'm
just not really like I it's alright but
it's not you know it's not it's not
polished so what we want to do instead
is change this into a much more accurate
way and the way that's going to work is
right now as you can imagine tiles since
we're on the tanks checking one location
of a tile where is it Center
the tile right the center of the trial
is obviously in the top-left corner
because that's sort of water draws so in
other words when we're checking
collision for the top-left corner
probably and that's why we're getting
this stuff when you can see that this is
the middle of our sprite when the middle
of our sprite actually hits the like the
corner here and it's kind of hard to
explain but when we actually collide
with this we sort of get this this you
know collision and let's go any further
but instead of checking one corner why
don't we check all four right we'll just
check all four because this is a square
it's not a dot so why don't we do that
we'll just check the entire tile and
that's what we're going to do right now
and that's going to basically make our
collision much more precise and just you
know better so if no actually not if so
we need to check every single corner of
detail so how many corners are there
entail four so I'm just going to make a
full loop I'll get it for I'm genius bit
seriously for in C&C sensor corner
equals zero sees less than 4 because
there are four corners C++ and I could
have made another joke there but I'm not
going to but you guys can't really guess
what it was um so in tech staircase so
right now let's just cover this quickly
so what we've got right now is X plus XA
divided by 16 which is basically this
right just pretend it says just to make
this really simple for you guys because
I know you guys love collision every
aspiring game developer wants to
understand a collision especially can
unless that's how I was back in the day
you know like ages ago because I'm
totally pro now so this is basically
we've got our so instead let's make in X
T equal to pretty much this right what
we're going to put two bars here X plus
XA right but instead we're actually
going to put our like code here that
will actually dictate the corner stuff
and then we'll at the end will still
divide by 16 okay that's what we're
going to do and YT equals y plus y a
divided by 16 but the code goes here
right
in other words corner code goes here far
as nose goes here all right that's sort
of how it's you know working don't like
to go to this and we'll move this into
the full loop okay so yeah so we're
actually going to replace cornucopia
with actual code so we'll actually say
is that um and again I'm not gonna cover
this too much in depth because remember
I'm making that in deficit theory as
series instead so plus C alright modulus
two because that's how we check for egg
for x-coordinates right we are it's just
same modulus the width which is two
because there's two dots in a square so
C mod 2 and then we're going to
basically multiply by 2 and subtract 1
and this probably makes no sense to but
I'll cover it in the in-depth version of
this episode and we'll basically just
paste this here so we'll change the
modulus to a divided by because that's
how we deal with why it's divided by the
height which is 2 as well and that's
basically it
alright that's actually it so times 2
will just basically make sure that it's
hard to explain in two seconds but
basically this will just just slightly
adjust the position of where the center
point is and now if we actually just I
guess preview this we're going to say a
change and the change we will see is not
actually ready up but it's the best form
so we get this we get this all looks
cool so again a few things that we can
change now first of all what kind of
halfway in the wall that's problem we'll
change that in a minute
but you'll see here that we actually
don't like we've got control now
basically so what we're going to do now
is I'm gonna pull the old goodness of
Java and that is pretty much live
debugging or hot swapping whatever you
want to call it so we go down here
that's cool but what we're going to do
instead is we'll make that two times ten
so basically this think of this
multiplication thing this number the
we're multiplying it it's like the width
of the collision area right because it's
X so it's with the width of the
collision area so if I save this you can
see that suddenly the collision area is
very big we stop here and we stop here
so it works both ways right but what I
can do now is I can actually add let's
just say 20 pixels to
it if I add 20 bits also it you'll see
that well like well with is 20 pixels
across and if you go here we can
actually go all the way here so if we
subtract 20 pixels it'll do the other
the opposite thing so we won't be able
to go here so we want to sort of find a
thing that works maybe around 10 pixels
because it is in pixels by the way maybe
like 8 will find something that works
pretty well and you can see that works
pretty well if we go to the other side
then that kind of works but you can see
doesn't really right it's just a bit too
much so we can still keep a but we can
just widen it to 12 all right
and that looks all right let's see what
this looks like yeah okay so now we can
subtract less maybe 7 and you guys can
see that this kind of trial and error
but you can see with this system we
actually have full control over the area
that is global so the area that is solid
which is awesome so now we got this part
now what I really like to do with Y is I
like the player to be able to pretty
much the head of the player to go over
the tail so you can see now that if I
collide with y he's kind of looking over
so that just gives it more of a
three-dimensional feel really but when
he comes to the bottom I obviously don't
want this because now looks like he's
standing on top of it doesn't look like
he's towering over a tile like he is
here looks like it's standing like just
on top of it he should really stop here
shouldn't he so we can just do the same
thing basically let's just try 12 you
know fun I guess kind of good maybe we
can subtract 10 that'll make it worse
why not add 10 that's kind of bad let's
see what it looks like here there it's
probably too much as well as now so
let's maybe add about 3 that's that's
actually perfect that's what this looks
like oh there we go so I like that
all right that's what I like we can't go
past here but if we go all the way down
here then you'll see I'm the yeah
we tower over which is awesome so yeah
so there we go now our collision is
basically precise and you know we can
adjust things if we need to so maybe 14
yeah check the other side here okay
that's a bit off whoops my bad
14
mmm no I'd be too much so it looks like
this side again trial narrow just go
through it make it perfect god I
actually got this like to the pixel
didn't I
it's pretty pro okay that's good all
right I'll leave it at that you guys can
experiment with it if you like so yeah
that's really basic overview guys we
didn't understand much but we did get
the coder in and hopefully you
understand roughly how this works we
just added this corner system where it
just checks for the corners and if any
of those corners is a solid tile then
you know if any of those corners belongs
to a solid tile then it actually says
solid angle to true not just the
top-left corner so that's what we did
this this episode I hope you enjoyed it
and again you know if you guys will want
that one so-called in-depth episode then
you just let me know in the comments and
we'll take a little look at what that
looks like I'm gonna probably call my
friend on skype because I feel bad for
jacking him all right I will see you
guys later if you did like the video
please hit like button I'll see you guys
next time bye
you